vous en met surtout sur braye monsieur
bros sur wii je ne veux pas en rester à
l'idée que madame le pen un discours
social parce que ça n'est pas la réalité
en tout cas elle tient peut-être un
discours social
mais la réalité de ces actes et y
compris des actes des députés du
rassemblement national au parlement
européen ça n'est pas le social par
ailleurs aujourd'hui a dit même par
ailleurs aujourd'hui je suis prêt demain
à des majorités de projets avec par
exemple la france insoumise
elle laisse vieillir une chose est ce
que vous avez vu ce qu'ont décidé ses
alliés autrichien il dirige l'autriche
en ce moment il ya un gouvernement
d'extrême droite en autriche
ils ont mis en place la semaine de 60
heures 60 heures de travail par semaine
et madame le pen veut nous faire croire
que c'est avec ces gens là qu'elle va
construire l'europe sociale
y'a pas une arnaque quelque part puis
par ailleurs madame le pen elle n'est
pas favorable à l'augmentation du smic
elle n'est pas favorable au retour de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune est
sans doute parce qu'elle est concernée
elle même est un chien qui n'était pas
vous non plus que la rive en tête dont
le 26 mai dont il a indiqué songer à ce
sujet c'est un scrutin à la
proportionnelle pas qu'elle arrive en
tête c'est un scrutin à la
proportionnelle
on est l'hymne aux eurodéputés on n'est
pas là pour dire ça n'a aucune
importance classement non ça n'est pas
jugée impact politique majeur sujet rien
le sujet c'est de savoir combien on aura
deux députés européens pour refuser ces
politiques libérales